we've been covering
what's going on in the georgia senate
race this is the race in which former
football player herschel walker
uh is the republican nominee he became
the republican nominee without even
participating in a debate and now the
question is will herschel walker debate
rafael warnock raphael warnock is the
incumbent senator a democrat in georgia
the back story on herself walker that
has been notable
is that he is almost unable to speak and
almost unable to express himself
and to give us his opinion on any issue
he's asked questions and he puts
together word salads of no meaning
whatsoever
and there are questions as to whether he
is even going to debate raphael warnock
recently
herschel walker has started to claim
that he has accepted a debate and the
language to the extent that we can
decipher it is bizarre it's about a
debate in raphael warnock's backyard
it's not going to be for the press but
it's going to be for the fans
and it's extraordinarily weird and over
the last week we have confirmed that
herschel walker still can't speak and
probably won't debate here is one
appearance over the weekend by herschel
walker on fox business
and he i i gather he's talking about
whether he will debate
but what he says is completely
unintelligible see if you can understand
it november are you going to debate him
well i've called him on two debates i
called him on two debates what does that
mean it means nothing on two debates he
turned me down on both of them because i
said what i want to do is see a fair and
equitable debate i have seen no evidence
that rafael warnock has turned down two
debates it's for the people not about
some press not about some party but the
people get a chance to see the
differences between my opponent and
myself when my opponent believed in
raising taxes during a recession my
opponent believed being soft on crime he
voted with joe biden to elect officials
that is soft on crime my opponent i
believe that he voted to put me in and
remember the question was are you going
to debate in sports where i do not think
men should be in women's sports so
there's a big difference in contrast i
think he's afraid to stand in front of
his georgia voters and stand up for the
record that he's voted on that that is
meaningless now if there is such a
debate i will cover it that would be an
extraordinary debate to cover
but
i am not getting the sense that herschel
walker actually plans to debate
how could he debate if he can't even
answer the question are you going to
debate it doesn't make any sense and you
know he speaks with this very scrambled
syntax and it's almost like trying to
decipher a verbal morse code to listen
to herschel walker but again i don't
know why it was ever claimed that he
agreed to a debate because the more i
listen to him
it sounds like he's maybe saying there's
going to be a town hall
i i don't really know here's another
clip of uh herschel walker
i hesitate to use the word explaining
but he's talking i guess about this
debate senator warnock
next star media group offered to host a
debate for us in savannah
now by the way these are the new videos
that walker's doing very clearly reading
off of some kind of notes even reading
off of the notes i still don't know what
the hell he's talking about october the
14th in front of the people don't be
scared
i know you rejected previous offers i
made no evidence of that but please
consider this one
this debate is more than fair to you
and it's for the people
is in your own backyard savannah right
you have hometown advantage
it's been hosted by a respected
third-party media group with multiple
outlets in georgia
it would be aired statewide on broadcast
television by the way next star is like
this right wing media company
i'm sure they would host the debate but
again nobody knows what walker is
talking about in prime time
so everybody will get a chance to watch
it it's a prime time showdown in
savannah
you know i mean
come on raphael let's do this
for georgia
october the 14th i'll be there
were you
yeah
um it sort of sounds like what walker
wants to do is some kind of town hall
it's not even clear what he's talking
about to be perfectly frank but i have
to tell you
when trumpists are your supporters
there's no downside to walker just
saying
i want a debate and raphael warnock
won't do it
and of course it'll be a made-up lie
warnock
might be perfectly willing to debate in
fact i believe he is but what walker
should do if i were listen if i were his
advisors i would not want him to debate
i mean he can't speak so how can you
debate
i would advise him start claiming that
warnock won't debate you make it up
it'll be a lie i think that actually is
his best strategy and a lot of his
followers will believe it let me know
your thoughts and we'll have these clips
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show